[inaudible]
game.
It's not just a debate.
It's an occupied spirit that cannot be
stopped as the former attorney general,
a prosecutor,
the governor of that state,
and not only accept your child,
you are dead wrong,
sir.
We cannot talk.
Know this is not 1989 anymore.
I wonder whether when they say,
I'll pray for you,
he gets that wonderful reply.
I'll think for you on the unselfish or
wearing a redundant,
I won't say it's too easy to say,
better late than never here I've said
it.
A lot of people in this world are
looking for an alternative approach.
We never dropped the bomb.
We never launched a missile.
We never fired a bullet.
I doubt very much whether they will be
genuine,
one man,
one vote,
but I would be delighted to be proven if
we mess up this one.
There's no other ones.
What done for
the war on terror was the right response
to nine 11 but we need to refinance,
not just have bankers.
Mintos think the whole of our society,
of course,
hip hop pomp enhanced the society.
We should be calling an end to the war
on drugs.
Barack Obama is ultimately an American
patriot.
The Catholic church is a force for good
in the world.
Are you getting the message?
There is a reason we hammer home these
use because they matter.